la artroscopia de rodilla se utiliza
para el diagnóstico y tratamiento de
diferentes trastornos y lesiones de la
rodilla entre los más comunes está el
tratamiento del desgarro de meniscos en
condiciones normales los meniscos trozos
de cartílago en forma de letra ce que se
encuentran entre el fémur la tibia
proporciona una amortiguación y
estabilidad a la articulación de la
rodilla las lesiones o la artritis
pueden desgarrar los meniscos lo cual
causa dolor en la rodilla inflamación y
disminución del rango de movimiento la
artroscopia de rodilla a menudo se
realiza para extirpar la parte dañada
del menisco al llegar al hospital para
someterse al procedimiento se le
colocará una viendo venosa y es posible
que se le administra algún sedante para
ayudarle a relajarse el procedimiento se
puede realizar con anestesia raquídea
que lo mantendrá adormecido de la
cintura para abajo anestesia local que
mantendrá adormecida al área de la
rodilla o con menor frecuencia anestesia
general que lo mantendrá inconsciente
durante todo el tiempo que dure el
procedimiento una menisectomía
artroscópica por lo general lleva entre
45 y 90 minutos
el cirujano accederá a la articulación
de la rodilla utilizando instrumentos
denominados trocar y con los que
realizará dos o tres orificios pequeños
o puertos
el cirujano inyectará una solución
estéril en la articulación para separar
las superficies y permitir una mejor
visualización de las estructuras
internas de la articulación a
continuación el cirujano insertará el
artroscopio y otros instrumentos a
través de los diferentes puertos las
imágenes de la cámara del artroscopio se
aumentan y se proyectan en un monitor
el cirujano examinará detenidamente el
interior de la articulación de la
rodilla localizará el daño extirpar a
cualquier parte suelta o gravemente
lesionada y utilizará un rasuradora
paralizar cualquier reborde mellado
si bien es posible reparar los meniscos
con pequeñas suturas en la mayoría de
los casos se debe extirpar la parte
dañada al finalizar el procedimiento el
cirujano examinará nuevamente toda la
zona de la rodilla a fin de detectar
áreas que presenten hemorragias u otros
daños retirará al artroscopio y el resto
de los instrumentos y cerrará cada una
de las incisiones en forma de ojo de
cerradura con unas pocas suturas después
de la cirugía se lo trasladará al área
de recuperación para monitorearlo y de
ser necesario se le administrarán
calmantes para el dolor la mayoría de
los pacientes son dados de alta de la
unidad de cirugía ambulatoria a las
pocas horas del procedimiento